Michael distressing news yeah
distressing news Lloyd Blankfein the CEO
of Goldman Sachs in a letter to
shareholders discloses that he has
lymphoma he has cancer he says that it
is highly curable and my doctors and my
own expectation is that I will be cured
that's all the information that we have
at the moment Lloyd Blankfein in a
letter to Goldman Sachs shareholders
suggesting that he had been to the
doctor the doctor has diagnosed him with
lymphoma Goldman shares down one and a
half percent premarket trading here we
have seen this before of course James
diamond of JP Morgan with a very serious
cancer a number of months ago in the
cure or yeah the good health of Jamie
Dimon was seen in Davos he was strong
and when I saw him a number of months
ago two months ago he was ever stronger
and blank fine like diamond says he is
going to be able to work substantially
as normal is his phrase during the
period I that he is undergoing
chemotherapy over the next several
months much more on this mr. blank fine
of Goldman Sachs still able to lead firm
daring treatment is the business
headline but of course which it reduce
plan travel but certainly we wish him
well